massen quarantäne nach einer
geburtstagsparty in dettingen mit 33
gästen gefeiert wurde vom zwölften auf
den 13
september danach wurden 14 personen
positiv auf das virus getestet
nun befinden sich mehr als 400 menschen
in quarantäne
betroffen sind schulen im landkreis
reutlingen zwei kindergärten und 70
mitglieder von vier fußballvereine der
leiter des gesundheitsamtes gottfried
roller betonte aber dass die feier
zulässig gewesen ist
denn die teilnehmer grenze für partys
beträgt in baden württemberg 100 somit
sei kein hygiene konzept nötig gewesen
dettingens bürgermeister michael hillert
erklärt wie das passieren konnte
vor allem im privaten raum haben um die
kontrolliert wir haben eigentlich nur
das ergebnis jetzt vor uns und ich
appelliere an die
eigenverantwortlichkeit jedes einzelnen
der durch selber drüber nachdenken
sollte sollte ich das jetzt tun oder
nicht und ich glaube dann müsste ein
jeder gesunde mensch ein gesundes
ermessen haben und da wo man sich nicht
sicher ich rate ich eben zur vorsicht da
scheint jetzt hier nicht passiert zu
sein
stefanie keber steht für uns direkt vor
dem gasthof wo die geburtstagsfeier
diese verhängnisvolle geburtstagsfeier
stattgefunden hat stefanie hat man denn
jetzt sämtliche teilnehmer dieser feier
feststellen können stehen die jetzt
tatsächlich alle unter quarantäne und
halten sie sich an diese
quarantänemaßnahmen hier hast du finden
sich derzeit über 400 menschen hier in
dettingen und den nahe liegenden orten
in quarantäne
also an sieben schulen hier im landkreis
wurden ja auch einzelne klassen nach
hause geschickt weil lehrerinnen oder
auch kindergärten wie wir jetzt erfahren
haben
kindergärtnerinnen zu den
kontaktpersonen zählen und das habe auch
zwei kindergärten im ort dicht sind und
natürlich einigen betrieben hier auch
ihre mitarbeiter fehlen
und natürlich unfassbar zu sehen welch
riesige auswirkungen so eine feier mit
33 personen mit sich ziehen kann dass so
viele menschen hier jetzt im ort zu
hause sitzen ja du hast dich um gehört
bei den menschen im ort dort in der
gemeinde ist die verunsicherung groß
dass
das virus vielleicht doch noch weiter
sich verbreiten kann nein also bei den
leuten auf den straßen mit denen wir
gesprochen haben war keine
verunsicherung zu spüren die leute gehen
spazieren die leute halten sich draußen
auf sind mit ihren kindern auf dem
spielplatz die kinder rennen draußen rum
selbst die cafés und restaurants sind
gut besucht also die leute halten sich
an die normalen chor ohne regeln und
gehen mit maske in die läden
zum einkaufen aber eine verunsicherung
auf den straßen konnte ich direkt nicht
feststellen
der letzte kurze frage nun haben sich
die veranstalter dieser geburtstagsfeier
an die regeln gehalten zumindest die
sozusagen an die mengenangabe 33
teilnehmer 100 sind erlaubt sind ist
einfach vielleicht ja diese regel zu
weiträumig zu offen sind 100 vielleicht
einfach tatsächlich zu viel oder hat man
sich dann auf der feier nicht mehr an
die regeln gehalten hat man da den
abstand nicht gewahrt was weiß man
ich habe mich mit dem bürgermeister der
stadt unterhalten können er meinte bei
solchen feiern
er appelliert an die leute sie sollen
trotzdem anderthalb meter abstand halten
aber natürlich lasse sich nicht
vermeiden dass man sich zehn minuten 15
minuten fähig zu fest mit den leuten
unterhält und sagt hat man sich schon
angesteckt er appelliert aber trotzdem
an die leute dass sie sich weiterhin
vorsichtig verhalten sollen damit wir
unsere gewonnene freiheit nicht wieder
einschränken müssen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren